the whole goal is to get the king by
himself remember that I played a game of
chess and that pruney room in there
that's the king we want to get him by
himself and then that's what it means to
solve the equation all right so first
one do I see the hand up not to give you
the outside but what would be your next
one this take the P okay so you what
we've done this just pause for a second
to see what he thinks that he's got this
minus 13 that's that's one of the pieces
he needs to get out of the way right so
that's over here on the right hand side
when we get away from the left put it on
the right okay so that 13 plus 16 is the
29 which we just had over there that's
good what does that leave me with on the
left hand side - no great - ah so that's
what I'd expect of you would do is your
next line if you wanted to get rid of
the 2 first that'd be ok but you see
we're gonna end up with the same answer
whichever where we go okay so now sorry
for the 9 bang now I only have one more
thing to do to get BR the King by
yourself fantastic if I buy this bike -
I'll just be left with ah and if I
divide that by 2 29 divided by 2 14.5 or
14 and a half they're both just
different ways of running same thing
thumbs up
very good all right number 2 let's have
a look hey I've got this 3 and this 7 to
get rid of which you guys reckon we
should get rid of first Eric in the 7 is
a good thing okay because um I could
multiply everything by 3 within my
numbers were just get really big okay
this is a minus 7 what's the opposite of
minus 7 plus 7 very good so when I do it
on the left hand side it disappears when
I get them right 10 because 3 plus 7 is
10 and then I just had to get rid of the
3 what am I gonna do next multiply by 3
so it's why it's very clear in as well
so that gives me 30 on the right hand
side okay 140 go this time it's a bit
actually don't have as many choices
really there's only really one direct
thing you could do to get that and by
itself what would be our first step
somebody's uncle ceddy
yet someone someone else's APA we got a
few people mention all of our you've got
this sword you are pretty surface like a
fantastic and you can all see what he's
done right where did the thirties come
from multiplied by four right fantastic
and then to get rid of that plus five
I'm going to opposite of plus five minus
five very good right yes 31 nailed it
okay and remember of course being that
we've got one two three solutions you
always know that the solution is right
because they should go back into the
original equation
for instance let's just give the UM the
first one to go right we said fourteen
and a half 14 a so if I said two times
watching 1/2 takeaway 13 2 times 40 now
if you guys told me
that's 29 you take away 13 and that
gives you the 16 which is what we're
expecting thumbs up that works and you
can do it for the second and third ones
as well